Film Courage: Have you always been an optimist? You seem like
a positive person from a short
time I've met you here and our email
exchanges. I know you have a nice saying
in your email it just gives it an
impression that you you know you're
positive and you're open to to just
different input from other people. Mark Harris, Filmmaker: Oh
yeah, you have to be I think. A big
mistake that is what I think right now
because especially as filmmakers right
because we control like filmmakers we
have so much control which we really
don't understand the power that we have
so when you go to the movies right a lot
of you know we set trends you know if
you look at Boyz n the Hood  if you look
at Menace II Society, you look at
Goodfellas right? People like even
rappers right rappers take their names
off of movies or off of gangsters from
different movies because we're what we
do is so powerful you know and so I know
that as a filmmaker I have to have to be
positive because if I don't then what
I'm doing is I'm just
aiding in the destruction of humanity
and I never wanted to be involved in
that I always wanted to say I want to
stay positive I'm gonna put that
positive content and I've been offered
for so many times to do negative things
I'm like no I'm not I'm not gonna do
that
and so as filmmakers we just have to be
true to us and be true but we just can't
do things just for money because at the
end of the day we doing things or we
just can't be in this business for money
because you will be doing things and we
won't be selling our souls won't be
satisfied you know what we we may be
passionate about filmmaking
but if you're if you're taking your
passion if you're doing things that you
don't want to do you losing your soul so
I always wanted to be positive I always
want to be put our positive content I am
I'm always positive know there's
something that of course not because I'm
human
sure you know and so again but I always
have to even remind myself like this is
what I would I mean it's always been
you know it's always been tipped because
you know especially when you're in a
position when you know you have to pay
your bills and it happens you have to
pay those bills and somebody calls with
an offer but an offer that's not that's
going to challenge you morally you know
and you have to say no I can't do that
you know there was no chances you know
those are things I've had to turn down
because of that I'm not just gonna put
out any type of images and things like
that
because we have to you know as you know
we have we have a duty as filmmakers and
I do it is you know first we have to be
true to us if you want if you want to be
in this business to make money okay go
ahead be in this business to make money
you know if there's plenty money to be
made but how are we what are we at the
end of the day ten years from now 20
years from now you know what I mean what
are we how are we going to change the
condition of this world you know and so
many times people people just want to
step labels on people we don't want to
really have true real dialogue so I
started having true real dialogue we
just put labels on people which is which
is very unfortunate yeah and I think
we're more divided now and in recent a
few years and and it's not just
politically but just in many different
ways and and it's it's it's definitely
um apparent you know I've read articles
too that you know we were just more
divided and beliefs or or you know and
it's it's it's a shame because you you
would think that just with you know
social media and and everybody's access
to the same tools that there would be
sort of an evolution where we could just
be I don't everybody would be sort of
satisfied with their own life because
they can put something out there
whatever their passion is and and not
think that they have to wait for someone
to quote help them but yeah I definitely
see that and I see in the comments - I
don't know if you can see it in other
videos comments and just how divided we
are right now yes would you say you've
always been a positive person or or like
this sort of open thinker or or did
something happen in life that kind of
changed you
in that direction I think I have all I
think this is this is this is why I love
my mother so much like my mother is a
die-hard Christian point-blank she goes
to church every Sunday but she never
forced any type of religion on us
and I never told you this but she never
forced us to go to church
she never forced religion on us so I
think that had a lot to do with being a
critical thinker and then when I would
ask questions I remember when I was when
I was I hate to be like have you know
eight years old and I had asked the
pastor a question the church I I want to
and he told me never to questioning God
and I was like but I was young and I
knew that something is wrong here you're
like why would not why would God would
not want us to question him
you know if he's secure in his word so
but my mom so I always always been a
critical thinker and from since I can be
since I can remember I never try to rush
into judgment
you know like ever trying to rush into
job I have to think about like when
things happen on social media I'm not
the person to just post or repost off I
have to research it to see is this stuff
is real you know is this like even even
even with President Donald Trump tweets
and people share his tweets I have to go
to this page to see okay is this a real
tweet you know and so we have to search
out things and to make sure that things
are actually like even as especially as
filmic is because we are storytellers we
should always research something before
we just put it out there you know
because again we we hold so much power
like artists hold so much power so you
know we're very familiar with how China
changed because of their artists you
know China was a country that was you
know and was in you know opium and the
prostitution but what they did was they
they put their birthday artist together
they said this is what we're gonna do we
want to use art we will use
entertainment to change the condition of
the
these people and look at China now as a
superpower you know and so as artists
right as artists what we can do is but
we have to come together and we have to
cuz you know we have to come together
and we have to start using our gifts and
our talents to change good we can change
not only America but we can change the
entire world if we just start to put out
more positive content you know content
that show more people to the content
that shows law of a concept that shows
more unity more respect
you know goddess of what we believe in
you know just respect people's ideas as
filmmakers you know that should be very
important for it important to us just to
show you know just to do more positive
because the thing is is that you have so
many so much stuff that's so negative
that the people are looking for more
positive content now again let me
explain to you it is the interesting
thing so we hear all the time how black
films do not sell overseas which is
totally false this is what people are
looking for and you know what Black
Panther proved that this falls but what
we have done with our independent films
we stopped we have sold a lot of
independent but a lot of our films
overseas this is what people are not
interested in overseas they're not
interested in the negative images that
as black team records that we put out if
we put out positive images positive
story I get so many emails from people
from Europe people from different parts
of America just said that thank you like
we did a film called black coffee and
it's this a couple of sites called it
one of the most positive life films ever
made
right we get so many people who just
emailed us in inbox us through social
media just thanking us for putting out
not sit I'm not talking about black
people I'm talking about people from all
across all walks of life
thanking us for putting out positive a
positive message in a positive images
and this is what people want to see they
want to see more positive content and
it's not that they don't want it's not
that black films don't sell overseas but
they don't want to see the
energy the negative images they want to
see positive images because you know
leave the negative images where you want
to leave them at but more people want to
see the more positive stuff and if we
show the more positive images of black
people you know as black filmmakers then
those films would do very well all the
things they don't they don't want that
type of stuff you know a nation nation
have to reach and have to give it all
you know we should you know so yes
that's the day did you always feel this
way I mean did you go through a phase
where as a teenager let's say you like
certain films but then you realize you
know what I'm not feeling how people are
represented in these movies so when I
came up I came up I was a big John use
fan from Chicago love John I used to sit
back and watches watch his films and
study his films and one of the things is
I love the storyteller I love the love
stories I can relate to those stories so
coming up those are the type of films
that I was influenced by you know then
you hear Spike Lee to come along you
know more of us you know and it's early
and stuff so many positive images so now
again I love me some good fellows I love
I mean I love mark Scorsese i love
martin scorsese you know so I look at me
I look at those fields but I always knew
you know but again like my favorite
filmmakers like the JA use my favorite
uh you know the Spike Lee's and I love
Kevin Smith - I know a lot of you know a
lot of people
talk about you know some of his films
and how you know but if we watch
carefully watched Kevin Smith's films he
sent some really deep stuff in his films
you know especially dogs my dog is worth
like his Dogma is like one of my
favorite films you know so yeah I mean
you know so but sometimes sometimes here
like even with if you just take Dogma
for example like Kevin Smith's family
Kevin Smith gives you his film like they
wrong there's a lot of profanity in them
but just listen to what they're saying
there's something a message that speech
that he's saying that we can like for
the people for a certain type of
generation so he's giving you - he's
giving it to you rob but he's also
putting something in it that you could
take and make you think cuz Dogma is
great that's amazing film it's funny cuz
he speaks like that - yeah you know he
may be funny and sarcastic but there's
like a point to what he's trying to make
yeah yeah I love this interview yeah
yeah it's very entertaining yes
you